YOUR MONEY IS NOT CHARITY.
IT'S AN INVESTMENT IN THE
GLOBAL SECURITY AND DEMOCRACY
THAT WE HANDLE IN THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE WAY.
>> RIGHT AFTER ZELENSKYY'S
POWERFUL ADDRESS TO CONGRESS, A
SOURCE CLOSE TO HIM TOLD ME, HE
WAS VERY PLEASED WITH HIS VISIT
TO WASHINGTON AND FELT, QUOTE,
REAL BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
CAPITOL HILL.
DESPITE THAT, SOME REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
RISING PRICE OF U.S. AID TO
UKRAINE, AS THE PENTAGON MOVES
FORWARD WITH ITS PLAN TO SEND
UKRAINE THE COVETED PATRIOT
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEM, A
SENIOR U.S. DEFENSE OFFICIAL
TELLS CNN, THE U.S. WILL START
TRAINING UKRAINIAN TROOPS ON
THE COMPLEX RESOURCE HEAVY
MACHINE, QUOTE, VERY SOON.
IN THE MEANTIME, CNN'S WILL
RIPLEY SHOWS US WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW ON THE
FRONTLINES IN EASTERN UKRAINE.
>> UKRAINIANS REMAIN DEFIANT IN
BAKHMUT, AS HEAVY FIGHTING
CONTINUES ON THE OUTSKIRTS.
RUSSIAN FORCES STILL POUNDING
THE CITY, AS THEY'VE BEEN DOING
FOR MONTHS NOW.
DRIVING MOST OF ITS 70,000
RESIDENTS AWAY.
THESE DAYS, IT'S EERILY QUIET
HERE.
SILENCE BROKEN ONLY BY RUSHING
SOLDIERS AND RUSSIA'S DEADLY
BOMBARDMENTS.
ONLY A HANDFUL HAVE STAYED,
BRIEFING THE RUSSIAN ARTILLERY
ROULETTE.
THEY GATHER IN UNDERGROUND
SHELTERS, POWER, WATER, HEATING,
ONLY AVAILABLE IN AID STATIONS
LIKE THIS.
THERE IS WI-FI AS WELL, A
CHANCE TO CALL FAMILY, GET A
WARM DRINK.
FOR DENIS, IT'S THIS THAT KEEPS
HIM GOING.
WE ARE HOLDING ON, SURVIVING,
HE SAYS.
HIS FATHER STAYED BEHIND AND SO
DID HE, BETTING ON UKRAINE.
WE HOPE OUR SOLDIERS WILL
DEFEND BAKHMUT, HE SAYS.
TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE ABLE TO
DO SO, PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY TRAVELED ALL THE WAY
TO WASHINGTON.
>> TO ENSURE BAKHMUT IS NOT
JUST A STRONGHOLD THAT HOLDS
BACK THE RUSSIAN ARMY, BUT FOR
THE RUSSIAN ARMY TO COMPLETELY
PULL OUT MORE CANNONS AND
SHELLS ARE NEEDED.
>> THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ALSO
THANKING THE U.S. FOR ITS
SUPPORT AND THE DECISION TO
SUPPLY MORE ADVANCED
ANTI-AIRCRAFT MISSILES.
>> IF YOUR PATRIOTS STOP THE
RUSSIAN TERROR AGAINST OUR
CITIES, IT WILL LET UKRAINIAN
PATRIOTS WORK TO THE FULL, TO
DEFEND OUR FREEDOM.
[APPLAUSE]
>> A PREDICTABLY LESS
ENTHUSIASTIC RESPONSE FROM
RUSSIA.
MOSCOW, SAYING, PROVIDING
PATRIOTS WILL ONLY PROLONG THE
WAR.
THIS IS A RATHER OLD SYSTEM,
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, VLADIMIR
PUTIN, SAID.
THOSE WHO ARE DOING THIS ARE
DOING IT IN VAIN.
PUTIN'S PR MACHINE, FIRING
BACK.
THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE MINISTRY,
RELEASING THIS VIDEO OF WHAT IT
SAYS IS A VISIT BY MINISTER
SERGEI SHOIGU, REASSURING
FRONTLINE TROOPS IN UKRAINE.
DON'T FUSS, KEEP CALM,
EVERYTHING IS FINE, HE SAYS.
EVERYTHING IS FINE, KEEP CALM.
BACK IN EUROPE, ZELENSKYY
SEEMINGLY ENDING THE YEAR ON A
HIGH WITH MORE MILITARY AID ON
THE PIPELINE.
BUT ON THE FRONTLINE, NO BREAK.
STILL NO CAUSE FOR CELEBRATION.
>> NOW, THE DETAILS OF
ZELENSKYY'S TRAVEL ARE CLOSELY
GUARDED SECRET, FOR OBVIOUS
SECURITY REASONS.
BUT VIDEO HAS EMERGED TONIGHT
SHOWING HIM MEETING WITH THE
POLISH PRESIDENT, ANDRZEJ DUDA,
THE OBVIOUS WAY, THE SAFEST WAY
TO TRAVEL BACK TO UKRAINE WOULD
BE TO LAND IN POLAND AND THEN
HE TOOK THE TRAIN FROM THE
POLISH BORDER TO KYIV, OR I
SHOULD SAY, FROM KYIV TO THE
POLISH BORDER.
WHEN HE TRAVELED TO WASHINGTON.
IF HE'S TAKING THE TRAIN THIS
TIME OR ANOTHER ROUTE IS
UNKNOWN.
WE WILL, OF COURSE, KEEP YOU
POSTED WHEN HE POPS BACK UP IN
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
MEANWHILE, ON THE ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE COMMONLY KNOWN AS
RUSSIA, THEY'VE ACTUALLY PUT
OUT A STATEMENT FROM THE TOP
GENERAL, JAKE, SAYING THAT
UKRAINE HAS BEEN TRANSFORMED BY
THE WEST INTO A HOSTILE
TERRORIST STATE.
UKRAINE HAS BEEN TRANSFORMED
INTO HOSTILE TERRORIST STATE
EVEN THOUGH, OF COURSE, IT'S
RUSSIA THAT STARTED THIS WAR,
RUSSIA THAT BOND CIVILIANS, AND
RUSSIA THAT HAS INFLICTED SO
MUCH SUFFERING ON MILLIONS OF